DAGEN McDOWELL AND GREG GUTFELD.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> WE'RE GOING TO WIN.
IT'S ABOUT WHO WILL TURN OUT.
GRANTED, I WON BY A LARGE
MARGIN.
I HAVE NOT SEEN ANY EVIDENCE
WHETHER OR NOT I'M DOING WELL OR
POORLY, WHETHER OR NOT I GOT MY
AGENDA PASSED OR NOT IS GOING TO
HAVE ANY REAL IMPACT ON WINNING
AND LOSING.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN VERY
CONFIDENT ABOUT A CRITICAL RACE
THEME AS A REFERENDUM ON HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
POLLS CLOSE IN AN HOUR.
EVERYTHING IS ON THE TABLE.
EDUCATION IS AT THE TOP OF
VOTERS' MINDS.
AN ISSUE THAT McAULIFFE SAYS
PARENTS SHOULD NOT HAVE A SAY
IN.
VIRGINIA HAS EMERGED AS GROUND
ZERO IN THE FIGHT OVER CRITICAL
RACE THEORY AND WHO SHOULD BE IN
CONTROL OVER WHAT IS TAUGHT IN
THE CLASSROOM?
McAULIFFE FOCUSES ON TEACHERS
AND YOUNGKIN WANTS TO EMPOWER
PARENTS IN THEIR FINAL PITCHES.
>> I WANT TO BUILD THE BEST
EDUCATION AND I WANT EVERY CHILD
TO HAVE A WORLD CLASS CASE.
AS YOUR GOVERNOR, I'LL RAISE
TEACHER PASS ABOVE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
OUR COMMONWEALTH.
>> WHAT WE WON'T DO IS TEACH OUR
CHILDREN TO VIEW EVERYTHING
THROUGH A LENS OF RACE WHERE WE
DIVIDE THEM IN TO BUCKETS AND
ONE GROUP IS AN OPPRESSOR AND
THE OTHER IS A VICTIM AND PITTED
THEM AGAINST EACH OTHER AND
STEAL THEIR DREAMS.
>> THIS SEEMS LIKE A BIG
MISTAKE, JUDGE.
I'M NOT A MATH GENIUS BUT I
ASSUME THERE'S MORE PARENTS THAN
TEACHERS AND McAULIFFE IS ALL IN
WITH TEACHERS.
>> WHEN YOU BRING IN RANDI
WEINGARTEN AT THE END OF THE
CAMPAIGN AND YOU HAVE LITERALLY
GIVEN UP ON THE PARENTS, YOU
KNOW THEY'RE NOT GOING TO VOTE
FOR YOU, YOU KNOW THAT BECAUSE
THE SCHOOL BOARD ENDS UP LYING
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT SOMEONE WAS
RAPE AND SEXUALLY ASSAULTED IN A
BATHROOM, THAT ALL THE PARENTS
ARE ABSOLUTELY AGAINST THE
DEMOCRATS HERE.
SO THE ISSUE RIGHT NOW IS
WHETHER OR NOT THIS RACE
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PARENTS, FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE TO COME TOGETHER TO UNIFY
IN A WAY THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN IN
THIS COUNTRY IN YEARS.
THIS IS A GOOD THING ABOUT THE
RACE.
I THINK THAT McAULIFFE IS OVER
THE TOP.
HE CERTAINLY HAS AN ADVANTAGE
FROM THE EARLY VOTERS.
YOUNGKIN HAS TO MAKE SURE THAT
HE GETS A LOT OF VOTERS OUT
TODAY.
THE BIGGER ISSUE I THINK IS THE
FACT THAT McAULIFFE HAS MADE A
DECISION THAT HE IS WITH THE
UNIONS.
HE NEEDS THE UNIONS TO HELP HIM.
THAT'S WHY HE'S GOT RANDI
WEINGARTEN OUT THERE.
HE PROMISED TO GIVE THE TEACHERS
MORE MONEY.
THAT'S THE DEMOCRAT WAY.
AT THE END OF THE WAY, IF
YOUNGKIN WINS, IT'S ABOUT THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE BEYOND
PARTY, BEYOND POLITICS.
IT'S ABOUT AMERICAN COMING
TOGETHER AND HOPEFULLY IT WILL
BE A MODEL FOR GOING FORWARD.
>> WHEN JOE BIDEN POPPED OFF AT
THE MOUTH IN GLASGOW
GUARANTEEING VICTORY, SEEMS TO
BE BASED ON WHAT?
YOU THINK HE KNOWS SOMETHING OR
YOU THINK HE REALIZES THAT CAN
BLOW UP IN HIS FACE?
>> HE KNOWS HE WON THE STATE BY
TEN POINTS.
YOU CAN DETERMINE YOU KNOW WHICH
PARTY THE PERSON DECLARES WHEN
HE VOTES.
WE LEARNED THERE WAS A HUGE
TURNOUT IN RICHMOND,
CHARLOTTESVILLE AND NORTHERN
VIRGINIA.
THE DATA SHOWS THOSE ARE PLACES
WHERE DEMOCRATS FARE WELL.
THE POLLS HAN BEEN TIGHT.
A BIG POLL THAT FOX NEWS SHOWS
THAT YOUNGKIN HAD GAINED POINTS
THERE IN THE END.
BUT McAULIFFE HAD HELD AN EARLY
LEAD BEFORE THAT.
SO WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE.
THE THIRD THING, I WAS SURPRISED
BY GLENN YOUNGKIN'S CLOSING.
I THOUGHT HIS CLOSE WOULD BE
MORE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE
COMMONWEALTH TO A NEW PLACE,
CREATE MORE JOBS.
HERE'S A GUY THAT COMES FROM
BUSINESS.
THE WAY HE INJECTED RACE AT THE
END -- MAY WORK FOR HIM.
I WAS EXPECTING SOMETHING MORE
FROM HIM THERE AT THE END.
TERRY ENDED ON HIS NOTE SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE EDUCATION
EVEN BETTER, I'M GOING TO PAY
TEACHERS MORE.
HE HAD TO DIVERT THIS
CONVERSATION FROM THE RACE STUFF
AND THE PARENT STUFF.
BUT WE GOT A FEW HOURS LEFT.
WE'LL SEE --
>> I DON'T KNOW IF HE INJECTED
RACE.
THE LEFT INJECTED IT.
>> IN THE CLOSING ARGUMENT IS
ALL I WAS SAYING.
>> DAGEN.
>> YOUR THOUGHTS.
GOING TO MAKE A PREDICTION?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE A
PREDICTION.
I WAS IN VIRGINIA OVER THE
WEEKEND, BY THE WAY.
>> A LOT OF SIGNS?
>> YES.
A LOT OF SIGNS.
IT'S SOUTH OF THE JAMES RIVER IS
WHERE I WAS AT.
IT'S RED TERRITORY.
YOUNGKIN HAS TO GET OUT THE VOTE
IN THAT PART OF THE STATE.
IT'S CRITICAL TO VICTORY.
WHEN TERRY McAULIFFE SAID I
DON'T THINK PARENTS SHOULD TELL
SCHOOLS WHAT THEY SHOULD TEACH,
HE MEANT IT.
EVERYTHING HE'S DONE SINCE THEN
AND NOW YOU KNOW HE MEANT IT
BECAUSE HE NEVER LEARNED FROM
IT.
HE TOLD CHUCK TODD TWO DAYS AGO
THAT EVERYONE CLAPS WHEN HE SAID
THAT.
HE THEN SAID VIRGINIA SCHOOLS
NEED TO GET RID OF WHITE
TEACHERS.
NOT BAD LOUSY INCOMPETENT
TEACHERS BUT WHITE TEACHERS.
YOU TALK AND INJECTING RACE INTO
THERE?
McAULIFFE IS ON IT.
LAST WEEK HE SAID TEACHERS ARE
THE TRUE HEROS OF THE COVID
CRISIS.
THAT IS SMOOCHING THE RUMP OF
THE UNIONS.
NOT THE MOMS WHO HAD TO GET
THEIR JOBS AND GIVE UP THEIR
CAREERS TO SIT AT HOME AND HAVE
THEIR CHILDREN EDUCATED ON ZOOM
BY SAID LOUSY TEACHERS.
THEN BRANDY WEINGARTEN SHOWED UP
AT THE McAULIFFE RALLY, THE
WICKED WITCH OF UNNECESSARY
SCHOOL CLOSINGS.
PRESIDENT OBAMA CAME TO THE
STATE AND TOLD DISMISS BELITTLED
PARENTS THAT THEY'RE IMAGINING
WHAT THEY'RE UPSET ABOUT IN THE
SCHOOLS.
SO THIS IS ALL -- SENDS THE
CLEAR MESSAGE TO PARENTS, HE'S
PROVED OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT
HE DOES NOT CARE ABOUT WHAT THE
VOTERS CARE ABOUT WHEN THAT
STATE.
WE'LL SEE HOW MUCH PEOPLE WOKE
UP TO HIS NONSENSE.
>> GREG, SOMEONE REPORTED THAT
TERRY McAULIFFE HAD LEFT HIS
WIFE IN THE DELIVERY ROOM TO GO
TO A FUND RAISER.
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
>> YES, I DID.
I KEPT IT UNDER WRAPS.
I DIDN'T WANT TO BREAK THE NEWS.
I WANTED TO TEASE IT OUT.
>> SORRY.
>> I WAS JUST IN THE GREEN ROOM
TALKING TO HAROLD.
I TOLD HIM, YOU KNOW, HAROLD,
THE STORY ISN'T ABOUT WHO WINS
BUT HOW CLOSE THE ELECTION IS.
I SAID THAT TO HIM.
IT'S NOT THE REVERSE.
BUT REALLY -- IT'S LESS A
PARTISAN ELECTION AND IT'S A
PARENTING ELECTION.
REMINDS ME OF THE QUIET GUY AT
THE BAR THAT IS BEING TAUNTED
AND NEVER GETS UP UNTIL FINALLY
SOMEBODY KNOCKS HIS DRINK OVER
AND HE BEATS THE CRAP OUT OF
EVERYBODY.
THAT'S WHAT THE PARENTS ARE.
THEY MAY NOT PULL IT OFF BUT THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA GOT
CAUGHT BY SURPRISE.
BY THE REAL THINGS THAT MATTER
TO AMERICAN PARENTS.
FOR FOUR YEARS YOU HAD AN
OUTRAGED MEDIA OVER TRUMP.
MEANWHILE, THE REAL ISSUES
SLIPPED BY THEM.
COVID MANDATES, CRT, CRIME.
WHILE THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS WERE FOCUSED ON
MICROAGGRESSIONS, PARENTS WERE
EXPERIENCING MACROAGGRESSIONS
THROUGH EDUCATION.
POLITICS IS A TUG OF WAR BETWEEN
PEOPLE THAT GO TOO FAR AND THE
PEOPLE THAT DON'T GO TOO FAR
ENOUGH.
IT'S THE LEFTISTS REALIZING HOW
FAR THEY HAVE GONE AND SOMEBODY
NEEDS TO PULL THEM BACK IN.
YOU SEE THAT HOW THEY HAVE
TURNED THE POLICE IN DEFINDING
THE PLUS AND BEING WHITE AT
BIRTH IS BAD.
THEY'VE GONE TOO FAR.
IT'S A SIGN FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
WHETHER THEY WIN OR NOT, I'M NOT
MAKING ANY PREDICTIONS.
IT'S NOT M